I think you better open up that register
[Music]
cash can be hard to come by in the early
hours of Red Dead Redemption too but if
you want the best for Arthur you're
going to need a lot of it the question
you need to ask yourself first is what
kind of outlaw do you want to be I need
your money if you plan on leading the
life of an honorable gunslinger there
are some practices you might want to
avoid here's a spoiler free guide on how
to make some fast cash let's start with
a few honourable ways to make a quick
buck hunting plays a big role in Red
Dead Redemption two animals have a
number of uses you can skin them and use
their pelts and crafting cook their meat
for sustenance and donate their
carcasses and meat to Pearson back at
camp to keep the camp's food supplies up
or you could sell them to the butcher
the selling price will depend on the
hunt quality sloppy kills for instance
won't net you as much as a clean kill
the return isn't always great but if
you're headed back to town and spot a
wild boar there's no harm in taking him
out
[Music]
if hunting animals is a bit slow for
your taste stop by the sheriff's office
and see if he has any work for you these
jobs typically pay pretty well and offer
a bit of storytelling for those
interested some of which are also quite
entertaining keep your hands up buddy
they only watch it for questioning
[Music]
if you loot a dead-end PC you'll lose
honor however you can loot the carcasses
of bad guys guilt-free they don't always
have a lot of money on them but many of
them carry valuables and trinkets you
can then donate these items to your camp
or you could sell them to a fence for a
nice chunk of change
hmm I'll take a look
[Music]
occasionally you'll come across someone
who's been bitten by a snake or stuck in
a bear trap desperate this stranger will
ask Arthur for help they won't have
anything to give you right then and
there but later you will stumble on the
stranger outside of a store and they
will let you pick out anything in the
store for free I always get the most
expensive item I can find like this
hundred dollar suit
now it's time to put on our bandana and
earn some cash outside of the law the
most obvious way to get a quick buck is
to well rob someone approach them and
open up the interaction menu from there
you should see the option to rob if you
want to go bigger you can also hit
stores this is a robbery open the
register now this is more lucrative but
also a bit riskier if the job goes south
you might have a tough time making
friends in that town
[Music]
this wouldn't be a Western if you
couldn't Rob trains a little more
preparation goes into robbing a train
but it's usually worth the trouble first
make sure your mask is on once you spot
a train ride close to it and hop on
after taking out the guards make your
way through the carts holding up anyone
and taking everything that isn't bolted
down once you've had your fill or when
the law catches on jump ship if your
horse is still in tow you can even hop
right back on and ride off into the
sunset
help people and other types of random
encounters and they'll often give you
tips on where to find more avenues for
money like homesteads ripe for robbery
so yeah it pays not to be a jerk
sometimes
well until you need to be a jerk and rob
someone's house but they're mostly bad
people I I think another great way to
earn money is by simply playing the
story there are certain missions that
will net you a sizeable take that will
keep Arthur going for weeks however most
of these missions don't come until later
if you find some other good ways of
earning cash let your fellow outlaws
know in the comments below thanks for
watching and make sure to check out our
new red dead show called quick-draw
where every week we focus on something
different about Red Dead Redemption to
[Music]